and Facebook is taking new steps this
morning to have users make choices about
the information that they share online
this comes one day after the company
released a short movie called facing
facts the nearly 12 minute video
highlights Facebook's efforts to battle
false news and misinformation wired
editor-in-chief and CBS News contributor
Nicholas Thompson is here
he spoke with a team of nine Facebook
employees leading that fight Nick always
good to have you at the table so you
spoke with nine of them they're clearly
taking very seriously what are they
saying they are taking it very seriously
they're sending the message we know we
made a mistake on false news we are
trying to fix it we're gonna try to fix
it at a very deep level so in that
conversation we went into how newsfeed
works how their privacy works and I
tried to push them on the hardest
questions I could so what will the
changes look like what does it mean well
over time they're going to use
artificial intelligence to try to
identify a false news to try to identify
clickbait they are also going to try to
adjust their core algorithm so it
measures more serious stuff which will
slow the way fake news spreads on the
platform now fake news we can we all
know what a fact looks like when it's
wrong but what about stuff that's much
more in the gray area which tends to be
the stuff that grabs us emotionally and
that's and therefore has more power well
not only that stuff that's right but is
misleading I mean it's an incredibly
hard problem which is why you need to
have a whole bunch of humans who are
trained on it you need to have the best
algorithms you possibly can and what
they're trying to do now with the public
education campaign is get us involved
because remember Facebook is basically a
compilation of all the data we give it
so if we're trained to say this is false
this is misleading that helps them
combat it so explain that so what kind
of choices will facebook prompt its
customers to make well there are two
sets of choices that they're going to
prompt you to make so there's one the
false news stuff which is happening
right now so please identify this as
false news we'll look at the way you
comment on it there's also a new set of
choices this has to do with GE PR which
rolls out tomorrow that is a TV PR
that's the general data protection
regulation it's a huge huge new European
law about how companies protect privacy
so Facebook on that is asking us to
choose do we want you to select this
data do you want to be sort of enrolled
in facial recognition do you want to opt
out of our data collection every company
that does business in Europe is going to
have to
change the way they think about privacy
that means I was when Marc Benioff of
Salesforce was there he was saying
that's the type of thing we need now
here in the United States essentially
with the European he made that point so
how will it affect US customers here it
goes into effect in the EU yep what
happens to the people here it goes into
effect in the EU but it also affects EU
residents or over here companies that
have used subsidiaries and the large
tech companies are going to want to have
similar data compliance in the US and in
Europe so it's gonna protect us too and
not only that the law it's way deeper
than anybody even imagines their
provisions in there mandating that
companies think about privacy from the
ground up so when you're building your
software you can't just say well collect
all the data we want we'll figure out
how to use it you have to be very
specific about the data you're
collecting the uses you're gonna have
for it and you have to tell customers
about it so this is a big shift
how will Facebook measure its success in
terms of combating false or fake news
this is another interesting announcement
they made so they've been very closed
off with their data over the years
they're gonna start opening it up to
academics and they're gonna say hey
academics if you want our data we'll
give it to you and we'll even
financially support you which is
complicated and then they'll be able to
study how much false news there is on
the platform and how it spreads okay
your Facebook has a line they you know
we want to get rid of a hundred percent
of it we have an obligation to it right
now we really don't know we don't know
if there's more or less than there was
last year giving academics access will
certainly help on that Thank You Nick
Thompson thanks a lot thank you tomorrow
we'll continue this conversation because
Facebook's vice president of global
marketing solutions that's carolyn
Everson will be here in studio 57
tomorrow